[Music]
hey guys I'm back with another great
Skype interview and this time we're
going to talk to Jennifer Rogers so hi
Jennifer
welcome thanks dr. Berg thanks for
having me on today
absolutely hey can you tell us a little
bit about your story of what happened
like when did it start and then what
happened after that
it happened at a very long time ago I've
actually been battling my weight for 31
years I went on my first diet my mother
put me on my first attempt at an
organized for-profit business when I was
always had weight issues I've tried
everything in the book everything legal
everything not-so-legal last year was a
very difficult year for me I was in the
process of saying farewell to my mom she
unfortunately passed away in April at
late March due to complications from
multiple health issues autoimmune or
apathy COPD heart failure all that stuff
and I was just disgusted with myself at
my husband and I we had gone out and we
had seen pictures of each other and I
was I was lying to everybody saying that
I was 225 pounds
sure add a couple 25 to that and you
would have been fine I mean I couldn't
sleep at night I couldn't I was getting
up in the middle of the night with those
diabetic tremors just going downstairs
and eating food and sanely we got a new
mattress because we thought the mattress
was bad and no it was just the weight on
my bones the arthritis was just horrible
yeah and we both I was destitute and we
were went out to dinner with some
friends and my husband was like well I'm
gonna try out games and the friend said
well hey try this stuff called keto and
we're like what is that and so my
husband started at first two weeks
before I'm like listen you started I'm
terrible at diets I never succeed on any
of them fine then we went and started
with a new direct primary care physician
and he was actually also very kedo
supportive and after hearing my history
of
weight issues diet challenges my health
concerns my diagnosis he's like please
just give give keto a month I said fine
you know I whatever I'll just try the
stuff I'll humor you guys I'm just gonna
fail again I had a call in to work with
one of the local bariatric surgeons lo
and behold Kido clicked Wow
yeah can you tell me were you overweight
like five years old or six what did it
was it since birth or was there a
certain time when you're a little kid
that you started noticing you staring
anyway you know um it was mainly my
mother always said that I look like an
emaciated baby but I if you picked me up
I felt very heavy unfortunately my
mother had a very poor self-image of
herself and she projected that onto me
and projected the obesity on to me it
really started when I started going
through puberty I was never a a petite
small frame child I was a medium frame
child but I was a child of the 70s and
we hate grains and we're Italian Irish
so there was carbs carbs carbs
everywhere convenience foods it was a
very poor environment I was in but when
I was about 12 my mom saw that I was
getting pudgy things weren't working out
quite well and that's when she started
me on the diets unbeknownst to both of
us as I matured that's when I was
diagnosed with a comorbidity of PCOS
with primary amenorrhea so right then
and there without knowing what PCOS I
actually wasn't diagnosed with PCOS
until my early 20s but I had the primary
Inman area right there but that right
there was the the indicator and hind
side of the insulin resistance and the
PCOS Wow now did you have heavy periods
around that same time do you have any
issue with your periods right before you
started kind of noticing your weight was
going up at primary memory is the
complete absence of a menses I've never
had I never had a natural men seized on
my own until too
taquito what's the only way I tried
eight years of infertility I was on
birth control pills the endocrinologists
said oh you just need to go on these
birth control pills we'll manage your
you know keep you regular keep
everything clean and then when you get
off we'll give you this magic pill
called clomid that'll work great you'll
get pregnant no eight years of
infertility multiple tries of clomid 8iu
is and to IVFs I was not successful I
would successfully conceive but I would
miscarry because my progesterone levels
were extremely low so I that was the
only way I could ever have a cycle was
through medication so so we're not like
11 or 12 or 13 you didn't even have any
cycles at all no I had a complete I had
no signs you can see that the estrogen
was coming in I was developing body hair
I was developing my breasts I was by all
appearances I was developing just like
my peers unfortunately I never
experience the natural menses wow that's
fascinating so here you are you going
through your let's say your late teens
and then your 20s and so you basically
what age did you start having that have
your first period again I never I did
not have in my first natural menses
until April 30th 2016 and I just turned
43 okay and the reason being was the
release of the estradiol in the first
month of Kido and since then I have not
had a natural menses again Wow
so I've been perimenopause since puberty
amazing so now what about like like
during your 20s you just like try
everything like the typical low calorie
that Atkins the 8th time I tried every
national chain weight loss center I
tried the only time I did successfully
lose weight unfortunately it was in high
school and I developed anorexia bulimia
and
eating disorders and then I didn't lose
weight and the stress of that eating
actually triggered my epilepsy so I also
have partial complex seizures that could
not be regulated through medication
actually through diet and and sleep and
other natural manipulations I was fine
but yeah throughout my entire life I've
tried the Weight Watchers I've tried the
Jenny Craig the Nutrisystem I've tried
to b12 injections
I've tried starving myself I've tried
yeah whatever cockamamie you know the
cabbage diet the soup diet the you know
ice chips and bread err i if you can
make it up I tried it and nothing ever
worked
Wow so so last year this is when you
started with 2016 you found keto what
weight were you at your peak was it last
year yes I was any I'd say 240 to 250
okay when I've started with the my
direct primary care physician I had
already
I started eliminating and reducing like
the sodas and some of the cards just by
association because my husband and what
he was cooking when I officially weighed
it was like 225 but before that earlier
in the year I was easily 240 250 Wow
so so you started the keto did you also
do in a minute fasting at the same time
or did you kind of do that later but
then after the first month within by
week 4 or 5 we we stumbled across the
intermittent fasting and we started
adhering to it and and can do a 16-8
very easy I tried to do at least in 18 6
2 to 3 times a week
Wow so did you did the weights start
coming off right away or did it take a
while for it to start kicking in because
of my insulin resistance and my
metabolic syndrome and so forth
I was not I'd started with the infamous
B pcs in the morning I was not losing
the weight I was getting frustrated
eliminated the B PCs and the
also through trial-and-error just
lowered my carb intake to 12 to 15
window so instead of doing 20 grams a
day I was trying to my goal was 12
XS up to 15 as soon as I started
lowering that the weight started coming
off okay
yeah and so so you started losing weight
and then what are you waiting on one
forty five oh my gosh that's incredible
yep that is I've maintained that for the
past three to four months so I'm I'm out
of maintenance with my weight as of
right now right now I'm working on
strength training and toning building up
the muscle mass incredible that's
actually miraculous if you have people
like coming up to you and just that knew
you before just kind of like is that you
what I've had that happen yes several
times I've been open about my journey
doing this and I've helped several
friends skin on the keto bandwagon in
fact I have two really good friends we
met up for a weekend actually three of
us we met up for a ketose girls weekend
did some cooking lessons took them out
challenging them to eat in restaurants
and trying some new recipes and stuff
combined at the time in June we had
combined lost over 250 pounds that's
that's miraculous that's incredible
especially yeah like the all these years
and Olson you just you know still in
your forties you're still able to do it
and you just found this thing I'm
amazing yeah I mean if I had not done it
I don't know where I would be today I
can just imagine the prominence of all
the autoimmune issues that were just I
could in hindsight again looking at the
symptoms and the feelings that I was
having definitely I was on the road for
some some really massive health issues
at this point oh my gosh what other
health benefits have you had in addition
to the weight loss I like to say we like
to refer the weight loss as the gravy my
anxiety depression I am no longer taking
any medications for that
I have battled anxiety depression mental
health issues my entire life my epilepsy
is gone I have not had any auras I would
have as many would call petit mall I
would go catatonic or it would almost be
like a twitch or Tourette's jerk what
was i I was having I've not had any of
those I suffered from chronic sinusitis
and severe allergies and where the
chronic sinusitis would emerge and
present itself as a massive migraine
haven't had many of those not taking
anymore allergy medication for that I've
had psoriasis and that's all gone as
well so my labs have come back great so
and then the then I've had some changes
with the hormones as well we've been
we've been tweaking that and working on
that it's really been interesting how
over the year my body it's very evident
how the hormones they AB and they flow
as my body is still trying to to
regulate itself oh yeah I could imagine
I mean let's just let's just bring up
the topic of anxiety depression mood
disorders I mean this happens all the
time the amount the direct relationship
between your mood and insulin in some
blood Sugar's low blood sugars mm-hmm I
mean it's probably so high as a
cause-and-effect relationship and people
just don't connect the dots they live
their whole life on meds and they don't
really know that you get off that sugar
you fix in some resistance your mood
just I mean I don't know what you feel
but it just brings people up well yeah I
mean I will be honest with everybody I
am a survivor
I'm a semi-colon survivor I battled it I
battled the demons my entire life it
could be at a drop of a hat where I
could have a massive mood swing and and
the smallest situation would be a
trigger it doesn't and especially with
food and I can now more sensitive and
aware of my stressors
where I may want something and I'm not
turning to the food anymore the food is
not the comfort level for me I'm at the
food is not controlling me I'm
controlling the food where I'm learning
how to reward my I've learned how to
reward myself without food as the prize
just the societal impact of everywhere
we go everybody wants to eat eat eat and
it gets extremely disturbing now that
you take those blinders off you take
that that and you see how food regulates
and controls everybody that even knows
that even think that they're healthy and
oh we're going to celebrate with this
drinking or this food or that food I'm
like no let's do something else my sleep
is amazing I had I guess I should have
been tested really for sleep apnea I
never was I used to be a horrible snore
and I remember that weekend away I've
known one of the girls since I was a
teenager and she actually woke me up she
thought I had stopped breathing because
I wasn't snoring and I would wake myself
up a story I'm also strep positive and I
have not had an outbreak of strep at all
I would normally at least two three
times a year start off with the sinus
infection that would relocate and turn
into bronchitis I've not had that at all
this year so it's it's really hard to
pinpoint all the small idiosyncrasies
that I suffered from pre Kito that I've
had not experienced this year at all
amazing I mean I still had the same
inhaler I'm sorry I saw the same inhaler
since last year I have not had to use it
for my asthma I love it that's amazing
what when's your first meal what time do
you eat I usually get up between 5:00
and 5:30 I do not have an opportunity to
eat until 10:00 10:30 in the morning
okay so I usually am in a window
actually between 10:00 to 5:00 is when I
primarily eat and then in the evening I
might have a cup of black coffee or tea
just something warm and hot and then I'm
done for the day awesome and you
doing a snacking or anything like that
nope nope and you find that your hunger
is less like you can just like your it's
more comfortable to go from one meal to
the next yeah
the only a lot of it is mental as well
but no I don't have those hunger pains
of those days rain you would wake up and
go oh I'm starving I need to eat this
I'm looking forward to eat this this
this you know it'll be like oh shoot
it's 11 o'clock I really should eat
right about now and then even then I'm
not truly hungry I don't feel those
hunger pains I don't feel that desire of
oh I must eat something it's you know
you've retrained your your body retrains
itself physically and emotionally and
mentally again where you're in control
of the food and you know when you should
eat before you get to those hunger pains
yeah I'm not mine not feeling those
insulin spikes at all ever doctor that's
amazing
how about about cravings do you have any
cravings I do I do and they're all fat
driven you know I'll make a nice alfredo
sauce or like earlier my husband asked
what we wanted for dinner is I'm like I
want a nice filet with some blue cheese
and mushrooms and a big old slab of
butter next to it he's like that's my
girl so I mean that's what I crave or
water truly I I drink over 90 to 120
ounces of water a day and that and I
don't want anything I can't to be honest
I cannot even go down the grocery aisle
where they have the boxed can cereals or
cookies you can smell the sugar just
emanating from those boxes and it mate
literally makes me nauseous now
disgusting and if you told me that a 18
months ago I would have laughed in your
face oh I could imagine I think you
probably the biggest problem is to find
what to use to scoop the butter out to
eat it right it's like okay how can I
eat that butter other than experiment we
have a butter crocks we haven't nice and
soft to go and yeah I'm I'm not
inhibited at all I'm not ashamed to put
butter on anything in fact I went out to
a restaurant the other day and I had a
cheeseburger Mike
you know that side of butter and they
looked at me they're like what you want
mayonnaise mustard like no I don't want
your over-processed mayonnaise I want
butter and it's delicious you know put
the butter on the eggs put the butter on
the cheeseburger butter is good that's
amazing when he went into ketosis did
you go through any type of changes like
fatigue as your body shifted over you
know I was very blessed and no I did not
my husband went through keto the Nikita
withdrawal to Kino bug I've known one of
my cousin's I helped I helped get
started on this she went through that I
never experienced any of it Wow now I
will tell you that if I get any hidden
sugars I am highly reactive and you know
I am not perfect
I have dabbled I have indulged in
carbage before and I feel it the next
day the first time I did I had one
cookie that I used to love and adore
within two hours I had a migraine
massive migraine and the next day I had
anxiety I was like oh I need medication
like why and even to this point if I I
don't like going out to eat at
restaurants because of all the
preservatives and chemicals they put in
the next day I can definitely feel the
eggs you know I will feel anxious go
well what did I eat why do I feel
off-kilter
oh wait I ate this let me look it had
hidden sugars or something to it so I
mean I just have to tell everyone there
is watching you know the whole thing
about being perfect the whole goal is to
not necessarily you know be the in this
mindless constantly eating like the
people that get into this habit of not
even being completely out of control so
as long as you're willing you know I'm
gonna eat that I'm gonna react to it but
you're doing it causative ly like you
know it's gonna happen you're not like
unaware and you're like oh I knew that
was gonna happen you know I just gained
a pound of water weight okay you get
that's for me and you know I I have high
respect for people like my husband who
have never deviated who have never
cheated for me I know I'm a food addict
I'm an emotional eater so
break that addiction to the foods I mean
I have taken a piece of bread you know
what is something that I used to love
I'm craving it I really want it okay
there it is let me taste it I put in my
mouth and go and I analyze why did I
want this it doesn't taste the same
first of all is it the texture isn't
that this and I kind of break that
emotional connection to it and I'm done
and I move on I actually end up spitting
the food out and for those that have
stuck with keto long enough and that
have deviated and have had off days the
repercussions once you experience you
know the headaches the anxiety whatever
your old symptoms were you've learned
your lesson that you don't want to do it
again and in fact if you love your body
enough time it retrains itself now for
me a treat is a frozen raspberry one
frozen raspberry I will put in my mouth
and it is it just totally that's my
piece of candy and I'm fine with one
raspberry Wow
I agree it's like um you know the you
have two things you have the habit of
doing it for so long it's ingrained as a
memory all the pleasures whatever
temporarily I don't have the physical
craving that your body demands it so
you're able to distinguish the two and
like oh do I really want this no but I
kind of remember what that like that
might have been interesting to eat that
and get the sensation like no it's not
the same anymore like it you see so yeah
I hear what you're saying yep that's
awesome
and I've actually helped influence my
father my 80 year old father and he's
done kind of sloppy keto he lost over 30
pounds he dropped his a1c I think almost
by two whole points Wow
and now we actually are working with our
son who is autistic intellectually
disabled he has some behavior and
cognitive issues and we have been
converting him on taquito and trying to
help improve those you know through
various studies that we're seeing that
are emerging of how with autism and the
inflammation and the neurotransmitter is
how keto can help and especially that's
how keto started was to help children
with
pull up see another benefit that I've
had that my vision has impaired has
improved I've worn glasses since I was
five
so for 39 years and my optometrist was
amazed that my stigmatism improved by
over three points in my left eye I was
mirror to legal blindness and now it's
improved by three points just through
Kido amazing for those people that don't
understand that there's a couple reasons
for that if you take a look at a person
with blood Sugar's with high insulin
with insulin resistance
they usually have damage with the retina
also keto intermittent fasting is
neuroprotective you can actually
regenerate nerve cells and your your
retina is an extension of your brain and
it's all nerve tissue so you're getting
more circulation you're getting both you
know more nerve supply so that's that's
awesome I'll have to I'll be curious to
how your your son does over time and
then also your husband he was
interesting because he if I'm not
mistaken he had a genetic problem with
cholesterol and he's stuck with it for
months I think I was like seven or eight
months and then it actually got better
and better and better so it just goes to
show you that even if you have a genetic
weakness you can improve things so right
yeah it's amazing all the different we
take for granted now the benefits of
keto that it's so ingrained into us now
how it how it overall is helping us you
know and especially with the etaf adji
the hardest part for me was the hair
because of the trauma that I went
through with healing my body in the
chemo I did experience the dreaded hair
loss but it's coming even better now and
actually I've had straight hair my
entire life and now I actually have
developed a lot of curl in my hair as
well so but for anybody that is afraid
of hearing that about the hair loss
please let them know it's simply
temporary you talk about like in a
minute fasting or kita hair loss yeah I
noticed just shy of about what eight
ten months I started losing more and
more of my hair and it really send out
especially up in this area my
hairdresser who has been my hairdresser
for over ten years was amazed at how my
hair she's seen that the journey of
quito with me and how my hair has
actually changed how I did lose a
significant amount of it but then how
its come back in in a totally different
texture different shade of color and
everything Wow so yep and I checked with
my doctor and he and he agrees that it's
due to it's related to you know losing
close to 100 pounds in in that year
window but it's just literally your
body's getting rid of all those old
cells and things that were created
before you know keto and just
regenerating and healing that's amazing
amazing story Jennifer I really
appreciate you sharing because it's like
there's a lot of people are in the same
boat and just hearing you they're gonna
want to do this so and I fit my wedding
dress is too big my wedding dress from
22 years ago is too big on me now I
remember trying it on it I couldn't even
zip it up I couldn't even get around me
and now I put it on and it went out it
has to be taken in so wow that's a good
problem to have
yeah I never thought in a million years
I thought that this was you know you
know was the fly-by-night the diet du
jour it is not it is it's anybody
everybody that I talked to I encourage
them to give it a try it's how we should
be
it's truly everybody can benefit from it
it's eye-opening it's helped us heal
ourselves physically it's opened our
eyes to how we really should be treating
our body holistically in totality and I
wish everybody would just give it an
opportunity if you can give it a month
to three months you're not going to
regret it
definitely not gonna regret it that's
right awesome well thank you so much
Jennifer for this interview this is
great yeah wow this is just as this is
like
bordered on miracle I mean it's actually
a miracle that will happen it's just
incredible like a hundred pounds coming
off your body so well done yeah yeah and
again I've tried every single the only
time truly I before this I was ever
successful was doing the infertility
shots and that's but I was on massive
follow stem and Burton X I mean my body
was so resistant to even those drugs to
get me to to stimulate for the follicles
that was the only time that my faceplate
you know my skin cleaned up my hair was
glowing my the weight loss would come
off was all for those drugs and the
reproductive endocrinologists the only
answer they had is just lose 10% of your
body weight and put going on that form
and you're good to go and I had such a
vile reaction to the metformin it was
horrible so gosh yeah Wow well better
late than ever you finally figured it
out and now here you are so that's what
that's awesome cool well thank you
thanks so much
no problem and I'll send us email those
pictures off to you in a little bit
okay thanks alright thank you have a
good one you too